welcome to this video on playing katsu
moto2 and he seems to play be a d6
player he had done this a couple of
games before this already let's see I
wanted to try them
the Petrosian system from change mm yeah
night is 685 and night a 6 other main
Museum don't know maybe I can get
something here
each voyage - okay
[Music]
hmm this looks a bit weird isn't there
something that I can do here
based on this this weird configuration
here maybe take first I can take Kim
shakes I have noticed snow useful
discovery yes mmm
okay Knight f3 let's exchange a couple
of times that's it's not leading to much
okay
I'm just going to take on age six a
couple of times Queen d2 chenggang long
castles check chats nothing great but at
least should be okay for me I don't
think I'm going to checkmate him here
but maybe I still have something because
of the space okay we'll catch one it's
not not harmless yeah this looks good
because of this queen of four idea the
question is though isn't it just look h1
Queen f4 takes takes root edge form I
can play F 60 x g5 my Lucas trapped okay
but the ponies is weak anyway on a form
can i play Bishop d3 or something okay
[Music]
no after that he might have to show g4
we get one Corina for take stakes
isn't that some way to get at the pawn
without any drawback Bishop d3 maybe and
ninety-two when I guess so
it still should be good for white rook
h4f six takes g5 there's really no way
to to justify that okay I could go if
five here this would be quite nice
statistically speaking he gets f5 though
for the bishop I have 94 okay so let's
play e5 him it should be good for a
slight edge
[Music]
because of the pawn structure yeah it's
nothing spectacular but should be a bit
better
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just taking that
black resides there was a Sun end it was
nothing special for me I mean just just
estimate a very slight edge because of
his slightly devalued pawn structure but
he has good pieces so there's nothing
nothing special for me here it's a
question no the conference to do this
still I was thinking f6 is good but 94
yeah maybe I should yeah this is really
the case yeah look h4 is still better I
should provoke f6 and now now do this
and it's this is better there is this
idea very often later and I have six to
play for maybe also Bishop g4 at the
right moment yeah this is good ok stock
fish is far too optimistic yeah it gives
one point six for white this is this
looks very very optimistic but ok and
this is this is a bit better for wider
and better than e5 this keeps a very
slight edge but only really a very
slight one here maybe Bishop d3 was
better at getting bishops of would help
would help me yeah he just he just
blundered the piece ok thanks for
watching